pour moi le bonheur c'est d'être avec
nos familles dit tu as été avec mes amis
et c'est bien jouer au basket reset
gagner un titre
l'argent bien sûr que c'est bien mais ça
fait pas tout c'est de marquer
l'histoire c'est vrai que c'est une
motivation qui me pousse justement a
toujours essayé d'aller plus vite que
les autres et d'arriver le plus haut
possible
[Musique]
non
je suis tout petit
biais c'est mon objectif et donc c'est
clair que je vais me donner les moyens
[Musique]
et
c'est pas parce qu'il ya des contrats de
l'argent tout ça que ça passe en premier
mois le basket pour moi c'est un plaisir
c'est un jeu quoi
[Musique]
je vais devenir un peut-être le sportif
français plus payer toute l'histoire du
sport français
tu lis ça je m'en fous car dans sa
crypte est au même niveau que zidane
mais les gens ne connaîtront toujours -
zidane parce que moi je suis aux états
unis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu es mignonne
voilà deux ans
[Musique]
et
c
moi j'ai eu de la chance soit de gagner
d'argent aux états unis maintenant si je
peut redonner en france aider mon club
je vais pas faire payer mon club
un salaire donc pour moi c'était pour
moi c'était logique de jouer au minimum
au minimum de salaire de 3
[Musique]
ma rage de vaincre ma ma soif de
victoires et de titres
j'essaie de déteindre sur eux leur parle
toujours
j'ai toujours rêvé d'avoir mon propre au
club de basket
j'ai toujours eu ce sentiment que
j'avais un peu envie de redonner à la
france par rapport à tout ce que j'ai
reçu
[Musique]
quand tu regarde l'histoire et tu
regardes les joueurs qu'on gagnait 4
titres la liste se rétrécit très très
vite et des fois j'ai du mal à imaginer
quand quand je vois mon nom à côté de
tout ça et je me dis que voilà je vis
des moments incroyables et j'apprécie
chaque moment c'est comme ça la vie
sportive façon tout s'enchaîne et donc
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile de
quitter ta famille alors qu'il a que
cinq jours ça c'est sûr mais bon après
c'est ma dernière en équipe de france
c'est ma dernière compét
donc j'ai envie de voile a terminé en
beauté
[Musique]
au début on savait à mon plan c'était de
rester vingt ans peur de finir là bas
voilà après la vie le business fait que
que voilà et tu t'adaptes et tu change
de direction
donc pour l'instant je préfère dire tu
sais quoi je joue cette année après on
verra l'année prochaine comment ça se
passe si je me plais ici si ça se passe
bien avec ma famille tous les trucs
comme ça donc je préfère y aller
maintenant une saison par semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi j'ai été toujours très attiré par le
monde dans l'entreprise et donc un
centre de formation ça existe déjà les
grandes écoles ça existe déjà
nous on a voulu relier les trois en fait
l'école sera le sport et le monde de
l'entreprise
[Musique]